eine seltsame ansammlung verfallener
bauwerke in einem pariser parc es gibt
keinerlei ordnung kein muster alles ist
welt zusammen gewürfelt und das macht
diesen ort so geheimnisvoll
ein vergessener schiffsfriedhof der ein
englisches dorf vor dem untergang
bewahrt
wir sprechen hier nicht von einem
einzelnen gestrandeten ruderboot diese
dinger sind überall
ein riesiger teils unterirdische komplex
der von einem unverfrorenen
vertragsbruch zeugt hiervon dreistigkeit
zu sprechen wäre noch untertrieben
1000 aufseher haben auch gerecht dass
sich alle an die regeln halten wenn
nicht wäre womöglich ein neuer krieg
ausgebrochen
und ein geheimnisvoller ort an der
ostküste der usa
im innern herrscht gähnende leere und
wenn man weiterhin ein geht sieht man
diese rostigen hinterlassenschaften die
darauf hindeuten dass hier etwas sehr
schweres hoch und runter transportiert
wurde
[Musik]
zerfallende bauten ruinen aus
vergangener zeit
einst mühsam erschaffen heute nur noch
schatten ihrer selbst
zeit ihre geheimnisse zu lüften
[Musik]
paris die stadt des lichts
paris ist eine metropole ein
schmelztiegel verschiedener kulturen aus
der ganzen welt
freiheit gleichheit und brüderlichkeit
diese besondere vision der menschlichen
demokratie umweht ganz frankreich
doch diese verwitterten bauten am rande
der stadt scheinen merkwürdig
deplatziert
die bauwerke in diesem park stammen
offenbar von weit entfernten kulturen
es scheint als wären sie aus allen
teilen des erdballs eingeflogen worden
vietnam tonga china
oder auch eine japanisch anmutende
brücke die von rambus sträuchern gesund
ist
jedes bauwerk ist für sich genommen sehr
schön aber sie sind ziemlich merkwürdig
zusammen gewürfelt
die kuriosen bauten stammen aus einer
zeit die viele pariser lieber vergessen
würden
man fragt sich was sie bedeuten sollen
welchen zweck sie hatten und warum sie
so nah beieinander stehen
die geschichte beginnt anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts mit der
eröffnung eines test gartens
99 beschloss die französische regierung
einen garten mit einem gewächshaus für
exotische pflanzen zu eröffnen
kathrin oder hat das dunkle geheimnis
dieses gartens erforscht im gewächshaus
wurden zb kakao und kaffee bohnen oder
vanilleschoten gezüchtet
das war aber kein normales gewächshaus
das war eine wissenschaftliche
forschungseinrichtung und woher kamen
all diese pflanzen aus den französischen
kolonie
im 19 jahrhundert wächst frankreich zu
beträchtlicher größe heran
ähnlich wie auch england und deutschland
hatte frankreich überall auf der welt
kolonie
es gab kolonien in der karibik
es gab kolonien in südamerika in asien
und in afrika vor allem im norden und
westen
das neunzehnte und zwanzigste
jahrhundert sind geprägt von vielen
neuen entdeckungen und die weltmächte
streben nach wissenschaftlicher
vorherrschaft
in der arbeit der französischen forscher
steckte großes potenzial
viele neu entdeckte handelsgüter wurden
im ganzen reich verarbeitet und
verschifft aber das erklärt nicht warum
diese bauten hier stehen
sieben jahre lang untersuchen
französische botaniker die pflanzen aus
den kolonien doch 1906 geht der garten
pleite
der garten brauchte geld der
durchschnitts franzose interessierte
sich nicht sonderlich für die arbeit
hier obwohl sie sehr wichtig war also
musste man einen weg finden die
bevölkerung für die kolonien und ihre
waren zu begeistern
um geld in die kassen zu spülen wird
eine große ausstellungen zu leben
gerufen in zentrum neue gebäude die von
den kolonial gebieten inspiriert sind
stellen sie sich ein disneyland der
jahrhundertwende vor hier sehen sie den
orient gleich daneben den afrikanischen
dschungel
es wurde ein riesenerfolg
tausende besucher kam sogar der
französische präsident
die architektur in diesem garten stammte
aus französisch guyana in china tunesien
marokko und madagaskar
es muss sehr laut gewesen sein die musik
die tiergeräusche das stimmengewirr
wahrscheinlich auch es auch sehr
intensiv nach gewürzen und kamel kurth
die ausstellung war beeindruckend es
waren viele seltene schätze aus den
kolonien zu besichtigen es gab nichts
was wir nicht gezeigt wurde inklusive
menschen
chinesen afrikaner mussten den typischen
eingeborenen gewändern posieren oder dem
was man dafür hielt kleidung mit
vermeintlich virtuell im hintergrund
diese menschen wurden als etwas
exotisches präsentiert ihre kleidung
ihrer sprache ihr verhalten
eigentlich sollte es um einen
kulturellen austausch stehen aber der
weg komplett einseitig die leute wurden
ausgestellt und bedarf wie tiere im zu
sehen die veranstalter hoffen auf das
große geld denn schon früher haben sich
menschen zoos als wahre besuchermagnete
erwiesen
von kolonial ausstellungen oder menschen
zoos waren nicht nur auf frankreich
beschränkt
es gab es ähnliche beispiele in england
und in den usa
london berlin new york überall wurden
menschen ausgestellt
angesehene wissenschaftler führten
systematische untersuchungen der nicht
kompass natur um ihre marken und
unterschiede zu klassifizieren
ihre untersuchungsergebnisse sind nach
heutigen maßstäben extrem rassistisch
um die kassen zu füllen werden die
prägnantesten exponate aus den
entferntesten ecken des kolonialreichs
zusammengestellt
abenteurer reisten in alle teile des
französischen kolonialreichs und
versprachen den leuten dort viel geld
wenn sie mit nach frankreich kämen um
den franzosen von ihrer kultur zu
erzählen
sie sollten den ticketverkäufen
beteiligt werden aber in den seltensten
fällen kam das geld auch angst die
meisten sprachen kein wort französisch
sie waren den leuten die sie nach
frankreich gebracht hatten komplett
ausgeliefert
[Musik]
die koloniale erstellung von 1907 bringt
tausende von 1 und sichert die zukunft
des gartens
doch knapp zehn jahre später ist von der
schaulust vergangener tage nichts mehr
zu spüren
während des ersten weltkriegs wurde der
garten in ein lazarett umgewandelt man
behandelte dort viele menschen aus den
kolonien die auf der seite frankreichs
an die westfront gekämpft hat
hunderttausende aus den kolonien wurden
rekrutiert um für ihre kolonialherren in
den krieg zu ziehen
[Musik]
die ausstellungsräume wurden zur
operationssälen für ausländische und
einheimische soldaten umfunktioniert für
muslimische kolonialtruppen wurde sogar
eine moschee erbaut die erste ihrer art
in paris
man könnte meinen dass das eine art
zeitenwende für diese menschen machen
dass man sie nachdem sie für frankreich
gekämpft hatten wenn schon nicht als
gleichberechtigte so doch zumindest mit
mehr respekt behandelt hätten aber weit
gefehlt
ein jahrzehnt nach dem gemeinsamen
waffengang von kolonialisierten und
ihren herrn öffnet in paris die größte
koloniale aufstellung aller zeiten
für die ausstellung von 1931 wurden in
sechs monaten 32 millionen tickets
verkauft die sogar ein nomadenstamm aus
dem senegal wurde gezeigt man fragt sich
wieso die leute dazu gebracht hatten
es ist die letzte veranstaltung dieser
art in frankreich denn die kolonial
ausstellungen kommen aus der mode
der park schliesst seine tore und die
gebäude werden sich selbst überlassen
[Musik]
heute versuchen kathrin oder und ihrer
kollegen die geschichte der kolonialzeit
aufzuarbeiten
teile des gartens sind heute noch immer
verfallen aber
2005 wurde er wieder für die
öffentlichkeit zugänglich gemacht
auch nach dem ende der kolonial
ausstellungen sind die nachwirkungen
dieser zeit noch lange spürbar
die tatsache dass das fremdartige und
das exotische auch heute noch konjunktur
haben ist in teilen auch auf die
geschichte der menschen zurückzuführen
[Musik]
vor der küste von new jersey liegt andy
hug eine halbinsel übersät mit den
überresten des krieges
andy hug sieht aus wie ein flohmarkt zu
militärtechnologie
einige sehen aus wie typische anlagen
aus dem kalten krieg andere stammen
offenbar aus zeiten des bürgerkriegs
angesichts der vielfalt dieser bauwerke
und waffen fragt man sich haben wir es
mit einer normalen militärbasis zu tun
oder ist das etwas völlig anderes
der standort der anlage liefert einen
ersten hinweis welchen zweck sie diente
die spitze dieser langen schmalen
halbinsel zeit genau auf den hafen von
new york city und das zeugt von der
strategischen bedeutung dieses orts denn
jedes große schiff das den hafen von new
york an läuft muss an dieser halbinsel
vorbeifahren
doch dieser ort hat viele gesichter und
viele geschichten zu erzählen
diese gebäude stammen aus einer zeit als
amerika nur eine kolonie unter vielen
andere wiederum zeugen von amerikas
aufstieg zu einer überlegenen
militärmacht
diese relikte gehen zurück auf die zeit
als die usa nicht mehr nur ein land
unter vielen waren sondern zu den
militärischen schwergewicht wurden dass
sie heute noch sind
all das findet sich hier auf diesen
sandigen flecken
am nördlichen ende der halbinsel steht
ein alter leuchtturm neben einem
eindrucksvollen ausblick bietet er auf
hinweise auf die ursprünge dieser anlage
der leuchtturm weist auf die
sonderstellung seien die wuchs in der us
geschichte hin er wurde bereits mitte
des 18 jahrhunderts errichtet
er wurde gebaut um den new yorker
handels verkehr zu optimieren diese
haben war für jeden der die
vorherrschaft im nordatlantik anstrebt
der strategisch sehr wichtig für die
niederländer für die engländer und
schließlich für die amerikaner
und dieser leuchtturm heißt den
seeleuten über lange zeit sicher nach
new york zu navigieren und wieder
herauszukommen
park aus soja tom hoffmann kennt die
typischen gewässer so gut wie kaum ein
anderer
andy hug ist so flach dass es selbst an
einem wolkenlosen tag zwischen den
wellen kaum zu erkennen ist und nachts
konnte man hier fast gar nichts sehen
der leuchtturm wurde am 11 juni 1764 in
betrieb genommen seitdem steht er genau
an dieser stelle
doch wie diese ruinen erahnen lassen ist
die flache küste seinerzeit nicht das
einzige problem
die geschichte des leuchtturms ist auch
eine geschichte des krieges sie beginnt
während der amerikanischen revolution
als die briten den turm erbittert
verteidigen
die briten lagen hier mit zwei fregatten
vor anker und hatten auch einen
bewaffneten wachposten auf dem turm
aber
1776 tauchten plötzlich 200
amerikanische soldaten mit zwei kanonen
auf der kommandant nahm den turm unter
feuer und schrieb später in seinem
bericht wir haben ihn eine stunde lang
bombardiert aber wir konnten nichts
ausrichten
[Musik]
rund 100 jahre später haben sich die usa
dramatisch verändert
im jahr
1874 halt abermals kanonendonner übers
handy druck
abgefeuert von visa verfallenen
plattform
doch dieses mal geht es nicht gegen die
briten die usa installieren auf sendung
das erste militärische testgelände in
den usa
ein testgelände ist ein ort an dem das
militär seine neuesten entwicklungen und
prototypen testen und sie eine
bewährungsprobe unterziehen kann
sie haben alles mögliche getestet
projektile zünder reichweite genauigkeit
die explosionen
auf diesem gelände konnten sie die
munition und die geschosse auf herz und
nieren prüfen ohne die zivilbevölkerung
zu gefährden
im laufe der nächsten 50 jahre feiert
das militär hunderttausende schüsse auf
dem testgelände ab einige der größten
und ehrgeizigsten waffen projekte der
usa werden hier getestet
doch die halbinsel ist mehr als nur ein
großer schießplatz oder eine
navigationshilfe für handelsschiffe
seien die hook ist von entscheidender
bedeutung für die verteidigung der
ostküste
ins andy hug ging es um zwei dinge
einmal um den leuchtturm der die schiffe
sicher in den hafen von new york lotste
und dann um die verteidigung in
kriegszeiten musste es andy hug dafür
sorgen dass keine feindlichen
kriegsschiffe reinkommen
mitte der 1800 90er jahre bahnt sich ein
krieg mit spanien an die usa errichten
mächtige verteidigungsanlagen auf sein
druck etwa ford hancock
des neunzehnten jahrhunderts hatten die
usa nicht genügend kapazitäten um eine
ausreichend große kriegsflotte
aufzubauen
stattdessen errichteten sie eine reihe
von küsten batterien um ihre wichtigsten
häfen zu schützen
hier standen 4 12 zoll moerser die
kreisförmig angeordnet waren die
granatwerfer sind nach oben gerichtet
die geschosse gehen also von oben auf
die feindlichen schiffe nieder
[Musik]
das testgelände von sandy huck wird zum
modell für weitere anlagen im ganzen
land
die usa beschlossen jeden wichtigen
hafen mit küsten batterien zu schützen
seit 1895 wurden 18 und 12 zoll
geschütze an festungen wie ford händler
geliefert um die us hilfen zu
verteidigen
der angriff der spanischen flotte bleibt
aus doch am horizont lauern bereits neue
gefahren fortschrittliche waffensysteme
aus europa zwingen die usa zum aufrüsten
hier in fort hancock legen sie den
grundstein dafür
europäische rüstungsunternehmen hatten
artilleriegeschütze mit rauch schwachen
pulver entwickelt sie feuerten schnell
und verschwanden wieder
wurde die us-version solcher waffen
entwickelt
dank staatlicher forschungsprogramme
könnte die us technologie mit der der
anderen mithalten
dies ist die erste und einzige
dampfbetriebene verschwinde lafette
hier unten wurde sie geladen und
anschließend durch die decken öffnung
nach oben geschoben um auf feindliche
schiffe zu feiern und da man nach jedem
schuss naturgemäß nach laden musste
verschwand sie dann wieder nach unten
daher der name
verschwindet
nach wenigen jahren sind die geschütze
bereits wieder veraltet doch das
wettrüsten geht weiter im jahr 1918
feiert ein deutsches u-boot 16 schüsse
auf ford hancock ab
sofort wieder an die us soldaten das
feuer es sind die vorboten eines neuen
globalen krieges
dem zweiten weltkrieg waren die
amerikanischen häfen vor allem zwei
großen bedrohungen ausgesetzt
feindlichen bomben und feindlichen
u-booten
angesichts dieser gefahren verloren die
großen küsten batterien an bedeutung
während des zweiten weltkriegs
beherbergt sein druck eine zeltstadt
unterkünfte für auszubildende und ein
mobilisierungs zentrum
in den 50er jahren beginnt das letzte
kapitel der anlage
dies ist das letzte verteidigungssystem
dass die us-armee hier errichtet hatten
die nike flugabwehr radaranlage sollte
russische bomber abschießen falls der
kalte krieg doch noch heiß werden würde
als die russen schließlich über
atomwaffen verfügten war jedem in den
usa klar dass die us städte extrem
hilflos gegen mögliche russische
angriffe werden
[Musik]
mehr als ein jahrhundert lang
konzentrierten sich die usa bei der
verteidigung new yorks auf das meer nun
richten sie ihre aufmerksamkeit gen
himmel
[Musik]
1956 wird auch sandy ruck ein neuartiges
flugabwehrsystem installiert es soll new
york vor angriffen aus der luft
beschützen das heißt projekt nike
die nike batterien waren teil der
us-amerikanischen luftabwehr
sie wurden landesweit in der nähe
wichtiger städte platziert um die
zerstörung von amerikas großen militär
und industriezentren zu verhindern
[Musik]
die neubestellungen sollten new york
city vor einem überraschungsangriff
bewahren wie er seinerzeit im pearl
harbor passiert war
auf einer dieser plattformen stand das
raketen verfolgungs radar die raketen
selbst waren etwas mehr als einen
kilometer weiter südlich stationiert
nach dem abschuss wurde die rakete von
diesem rat ladens ziel gelenkt während
ein anderes radar zeitgleich das ziel
verfolgte ein computer fügt die daten
dann zusammen so dass ein treffer
garantiert war
doch wie alle waffen und
verteidigungssysteme auf sandy huck hat
auf nike nur eine kurze lebensdauer
1974 wird das programm eingestampft und
die us-armee verlässt die halbinsel
was bleibt sind verfallene ruinen die
vom herrchen küstenwind verwittert sind
sie zeugen von der bewegten geschichte
sind die hooks und der geburt einer
nation
all diese artefakte spiegeln den
aufstieg amerikas zu einer weltmacht
wieder den weg von der instabilen
kolonie des britischen weltreichs hin zu
einer mächtigen nation die sich mit
spitzentechnologie gegen die
kommunistische bedrohung stemmte all das
ist hier aufs handy holen
[Musik]
im süden englands des dorfs perten liegt
eine geister flotte am ufer eines
breiten flusses
sie sehen aus wie boote scheinen aber
aus beton zu sein liest man boote aus
beton sind dass staaten die
seltsamen objekte liegen halb versunken
im cern dem längsten fluss
großbritanniens
manche der boote sind so tief vergraben
dass nur noch die verrottete bugspitze
herausragen
der boots friedhof erstreckt sich über
zweieinhalb kilometer am ufer des
flusses
es gibt sehr viele boote und sie
scheinen schon lange da zu sein
man könnte meinen jemand hätte sie
absichtlich dort platziert aber das land
hat sie sich vollständig einverleibt
der herren und ein parallel verlaufender
kanal verbinden könnten mit dem rest
englands
ist ein großer fluss und direkt daneben
ein kanal welchen sinn ergibt
vor fast 50 jahren macht der junge paul
barnett mit seinen eltern einen ausflug
ans flussufer
ich habe ja als kind sehr gerne gespielt
bernard und sein vater stoßen auf
seltsame objekte die aus dem schlamm
hervorragend doch sie können sich keinen
reim darauf machen
mein vater war seemann und hat er die
sache aus seiner brille betrachtet er
glaubte dass es sich hierbei um einen
friedhof für ausrangierte boote handelt
aber sicher wussten wie es nicht
das geheimnis des boots friedhofs bleibt
ungelöst bis bald zwanzig jahre später
zurückkehrt und es duftet
zuerst hatte ich die örtlichen archive
durchforstet aber da war kaum etwas zu
finden das hatte mich schon sehr
erstaunt dass es darüber keine
informationen
diese dinger stechen ins auge wenn
jemand sie mit absicht hier abgelegt hat
dann müsste das eigentlich aktenkundig
seien
paul barnett weitet seine untersuchungen
aus
er befasst sich mit der geschichte des
essens und stößt tatsächlich auf erste
hinweise
auch wenn das nicht so aussieht aber
diese gegend ist sehr gefährlich
die strömungen im verein ist unglaublich
türkisch sie fließt hier mit bis zu 13
knoten
[Musik]
ist gefährlich ganz im gegensatz zum
angrenzenden kanal
direkt neben diesen mächtigen fluss
verläuft ein kanal vor 200 jahren waren
solche kanäle die wichtigsten
transportrouten für den güterverkehr in
großbritannien die menschen waren auf
sie angewiesen das waren wichtige
versorgung sei dann auch hier im dorf
person
der schaden ist kann er wird 1827
eingeweiht
er schließt burton an das
versorgungsnetz des königreichs an
doch er hat eine entscheidende
schwachstelle
der kanal ist ein wichtiges
infrastrukturprojekt
doch zwischen ihm und dem reißenden
fluss gibt es nur einen schmalen
erdwalls
an manchen stellen ist dieser aufschwung
gerade einmal sechs meter breit
wenn der fluss mit seiner ganzen gewalt
auf das flussufer trifft kommt es zur
erosion und zwar tag für tag
der erdwall hält das wasser zurück ohne
ihn würde der fluss den kanal
verschlingen
ein jahrhundert lang fließen kanal und
fluss friedlich seite an seite doch 1909
kommt es zur katastrophe
ein gewaltiger sturm im südwesten
englands hat das wasser des southern
über das ufer in den kanal gespült
die sturmflut hat das ufer mit voller
wucht getroffen reißenden strömungen
haben einen etwa 60 meter langen teil
abgetragen und mit sich gerissen
tonnenweise schmutz und schlamm flossen
stromabwärts
fast 60 meter der aufschüttung werden
weggespült
der kanal dann drohte komplett zu
brechen es musste etwas passieren
[Musik]
der sturm hat den ufa damm schwer
beschädigt eine steinerne flotte soll
die lücke schließen
für große restaurierungsprojekte war in
diesen kleinen teil england einfach kein
geld da zudem war die zeit knapp
doch dann hatte der leitende kanalbauer
eine radikale idee
der ingenieur der
hafenbetriebsgesellschaft bat die leute
ihre ausrangierten boote herr zu bringen
um das kanalufer zu verstärken
damit der plan aufgehen brauchte man
eine ganze flotte von booten als die
dorfbewohner davon hörten alten sie
sofort zum schluss
insgesamt 15 holzkähne werden nach paten
geschleppt
dies war das erste boot das auf grund
gesetzt wurde 20 minuten vor der hoch
flut wurde es mit voller wucht ins ufer
getrieben
der plan war die boots wende anzubohren
damit wasser eindringen kann
in den boden und drum herum sollten sich
dann schlick und schlamm ablagern um das
flussufer wieder aufzubauen
die boote sollen den kanal vor den
fluten des seven schützen sie werden per
text genannt die schiffsrümpfe von paten
doch wie sich zeigt ist der seven
stärker als der improvisierte schutzwall
das problem mit holz es verortet
die holzplanken vermoderten und der
kanal war kurz darauf wieder gefährt
holzboote verrotten und metall boote
rosten doch zum glück hatte die
geschichte eine lösung parat
nach dem ersten weltkrieg schießen die
preise für holz und metall in die höhe
herkömmliche boote sind für viele nicht
mehr erschwinglich
die schiffsbauer fing an mit beton zu
arbeiten beton boote waren schnell und
billig zu bauen aber sie waren verdammt
schwer zu steuern
für die befestigung des flussufers
bieten sich ausrangierte beton boote
geradezu an in den 1960 er werden acht
von ihnen zu den partnershops gebracht
60 jahre später ist der damm dank der
boote auf die doppelte breite
angewachsen der kanal ist gerettet
du kannst nur mit dem wasser arbeiten
niemals dagegen ich bin beeindruckt mit
wie viel seemanns können die boote die
befestigten
bis zum heutigen tage verleihen die
paten heicks dem ufer stabilität
seit 60 jahren schützen sie den kanal
vor dem mächtigen stepper sie sind ein
toller beweis für den menschlichen
erfindergeist
[Musik]
in der entlegenen landschaft west polens
ist ein gigantisches bauwerk verborgen
auf den ersten blick wirkt die
landschaft eher unauffällig aber
dann fallen einem leser verstreuten
bunker ins auge
sieht man einen dann noch eine und wenn
man den blick schweifen lässt scheint
das endlos so weiterzugehen offenbar ist
das eine sehr große anlage
wie die maginot-linie in frankreich nur
dass wir nicht in frankreich sind die
bunker sind teil einer riesigen
unterirdischen festung
unter der erde verläuft ein gigantisches
tunnel netzwerk zum teil sind dort sogar
schienen verlegt
die menschen die hier gearbeitet haben
sind zwar schon lange weg aber sie haben
hinweise hinterlassen was hier passiert
ist über einen durchgang steht das wort
maschinen
diesem bau steckt offensichtlich
wahnsinnig viel arbeit aber am ende kam
nichts dabei heraus
insgesamt 32 kilometer tunnel
durchziehen den polnischen untergrund
ein bauwerk an der oberfläche liefert
einen ersten hinweis auf den zweck
dieser anlage
oberhalb der anlage verläuft eine
seltsame brücke sie ist der schlüssel
zum verständnis dass
welche geheimnisse liegen ihr verborgen
[Musik]
das gigantische bauwerk erstreckt sich
über knapp 64 kilometer zum teil
oberirdisch zum teil unter der erde
ein großer teil der anlage etwa die
tunnel oder die eisenbahnschienen liegt
unter der erde doch der entscheidende
hinweis worum es sich hierbei handelt
befindet sich an der oberfläche eine
brücke mit einem seltsamen drehgelenk
der historiker und architekt robert yoga
erforscht diese historisch bedeutsame
städte seit vielen jahren
[Musik]
diese brücke ist bis heute
patentgeschützt die entsprechenden
unterlagen lägen in berlin aufgrund der
hohen sicherheitsstufe durften nur
speziell ausgebildete soldaten sie
bedienen
drei brücken wie diese dienen dazu
schiffe auf großen flüssen passieren zu
lassen doch dieser fluss gleicht eher
einem rinnsal
die drehbrücke steht hier weil diese
ganze befestigungsanlage illegal war
[Musik]
die brücke liegt im westen polens rund
60 kilometer von der deutschen grenze
entfernt sie ist teil eines geheimen
befestigungs programms dessen ursprünge
bis zum ersten weltkrieg zurück reichen
damals gehörte dieser landstrich noch zu
deutschland
denken wir zurück ans ende des ersten
weltkriegs deutschland hatte den krieg
gegen die alliierten verloren wurde
entwaffnet und von gemäß dem versailler
vertrag teile seiner gebiete und seine
bevölkerung
der vertrag war eine demütigung für
deutschland das land musste seine
kolonien abgeben einige der
industriezentren wurden besetzt und die
armee schrumpfte auf 100.000 soldaten
zusammen
auch wird es deutschland untersagt
befestigungsanlagen an den grenzen zu
errichten
deutschland ist praktisch wehrlos
die deutschen fühlten sich sehr
verwundbar nach ende des ersten
weltkriegs waren sie in der ganzen welt
verhasst und im osten lauerten gleich
zwei feinde polen und dahinter die
sowjetunion
deutschland hätte einer invasion aus dem
osten nichts entgegensetzen können die
größte schwachstelle ist die region
zwischen den flüssen oder und warthe das
land ist flach es gibt kaum natürliche
barrieren und der weg führt direkt nach
berlin
für die polen und die sowjets wäre es
das perfekte einfallstor gewesen
geradewegs nach berlin in die hauptstadt
dieses loch in der verteidigungslinie
wollten die deutschen unbedingt stoppen
deutschland schmiedet einen plan um die
bestimmungen des versailler vertrages zu
umgehen
der versailler vertrag hat zwar ausgaben
für militär und befestigungen
ausdrücklich begrenzt aber da stand
nicht über wasserwege
also hat die regierung ingenieure
eingestellt hunderte tonnen erde
ausheben lassen flüsse geleitet und eine
neue natürliche barriere geschaffen
der wichtigste schutz vor panzern war
wasser um feindliche panzer abzuhalten
haben die deutschen taktische kanäle
angelegt und eine reihe taktischer
brücken darüber gebaut
[Musik]
mehrere brücken überspannen einen
künstlichen wasserweg sollte der feind
sich auf den weg machen werden die
routen dicht gemacht
im fall eines einmarschs hätte man die
brücken geschlossen und im alltag haben
fußgänger sie genutzt
innerhalb von fünf jahren entsteht eine
geschlossene verteidigungslinie zwischen
den flüssen oder und warthe der beginn
der festungs front oder erwachte bogen
auch ostwall genannt
von einer dreistheit zu sprechen wäre
noch untertrieben
1000 auf see erwarten darüber dass
deutschland sich an die regeln hält kein
verstoß hätte womöglich zu einem neuen
krieg geführt
die deutsche regierung ordnet den bau
von tunneln und bunkern am der ostwall
wird zu einer modernen festung ausgebaut
doch als hitler die anlage 1938
besichtigt ist eher wenig begeistert als
hitler 1938 den ostwall besuchte war er
definitiv enttäuscht da war jemand der
seine macht offen zur schau stellen
wollte mit panzer paraden auf den
straßen und bombern und kampfflugzeugen
im himmel mit
einer unterirdischen festungen mit
kleinen geschützen zwischen bäumen
hervor locken konnte er nichts angst
1939 wird im schutz der westgrenze
priorität eingeräumt der ausbau des ost
waltz wird auf eis gelegt im selben jahr
marschiert hitler in polen ein die
tunnel werden sich selbst überlassen
bis hitler eine neue verwendung für sie
findet
nachdem hitler den baustopp verhängt
hatte lag der ostwall erst einmal brach
doch als die alliierten anfingen
strategische ziele zu bombardieren wurde
die anlage einem neuen zweck zugeführt
den bau von flugzeugtriebwerken
da alle kriegs tauglichen männer an der
front sind bleibt für die verteidigung
des ost walz nur ein kümmerliches her
normale soldaten gab es dort nicht nur
schlecht ausgebildete mitglieder der
hitlerjugend und männer die zu alt für
die front waren
die bedingungen waren furchtbar es war
dunkel es gab mangel an allen ecken und
enden niemand kümmerte sich um die
menschen hier die front war hunderte
kilometer entfernt doch das sollte sich
bald
ende 1944 ist die wehrmacht in der
defensive die sowjets nähern sich berlin
hitler war nicht gerade ein gewiefter
kriegstaktik
er weigerte sich den rückzug anzuordnen
so wurden hunderttausende deutsche
soldaten von der roten armee umzingelt
und gefangen genommen
zwischen den sowjets und berlin nur noch
dieses kleine stückchen des ost walz lag
der ostwall und seine soldaten stehen
vor der ultimativen
bewährungsprobe
die feindlichen truppen kamen von dort
drüben zuerst mussten sie die
panzersperre auf der straße überwinden
die grünschnäbel aus der hitlerjugend
und die alten kerle hatten keine chance
gegen die rote armee aber das hat sie
nicht davon abgehalten widerstand zu
leisten
sie wollten die festung verteidigen
binnen weniger tage durchbricht die rote
armee die anlage und rollt auf berlin zu
das traurige ist dass die deutschen nach
all der hinterlistigen planung und all
den hoffnungen nicht mal bereit waren
ausreichend männer und ressourcen in die
einrichtung zu stecken so wurde aus
einer lahmen ente ein rohrkrepierer
wäre diese anlage wie geplant beendet
worden hätte sie der deutschen armee
wertvolle dienste leisten können aber so
wurde nur ein drittel fertig gestellt
ohne panzerabwehrwaffen hatten die
soldaten keine chance gegen die
schlagkraft der sowjetischen armee
[Musik]
nach kriegsende wurden die grenzen neu
gezogen das gebiet des ostwald polen
zugeschlagen dem land vor dem man sich
eigentlich schützen wollte
[Musik]
gerüchten zufolge soll im most weil ein
geheimer nazi schatz versteckt sein doch
das einzig wertvolle in diesen dunklen
fluren sind die rund 35.000 geschützten
fledermäuse die hier heute leben
[Musik]
heute sind viele der bauten vergessen
und verlassen manche ruinen erinnern an
dunkle zeiten andere waren einst
leuchtende beispiele für technologischen
fortschritt und hoffnung stille zeugen
von erfindungsreichtum
unternehmergeist und tatendrang